hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd and
a bit of a mess i don't know about you
but over the last year with lockdowns
and working from home and general stress
my daily routine has just gone out the
window i keep losing track
of when i last changed my sheets when i
should be eating lunch when i should go
to sleep
some days i've even forgotten to shower
until it's too late for me to shower
so a lot of nights i just haven't had
the energy to do a proper full skincare
routine
it's sort of like the last thing on my
mind and with mask wearing my skin has
needed more attention
i'm getting a lot of congestion around
my chin and i might be starting to
develop a little bit of perioral
dermatitis
so today i thought i'd talk about some
skin care products that i found really
helpful
when i've just been too lazy to do a
proper routine or when i have to play
catch-up with my skincare let me know
what products you like using for this if
you use the same products as me
if you like talking about the science
behind beauty products click the like
the subscribe and the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos
i'm going to start with today's video
sponsor and it's a product that i think
a lot of you knew i was going to talk
about for this which is
bioderma's micellar water i talk about
this a lot but analyzing an ingredients
list is useful to an extent
but because products are so complex you
can't tell everything just from the
ingredients list
that's why testing products on actual
people getting clinical evidence
is so valuable in getting science-based
skin care
and that's why so many skin care experts
scientists dermatologists
estheticians recommend bioderma all the
time they are so
thorough with their clinical testing
they collaborate with research
institutes and dermatologists to create
their products
and that means they end up with products
that just work really well
for a lot of people i've raved about
their micellar water before and it's
become such a staple for me over the
last year
this is actually the world's first
micellar water it's the product that
started the craze
it's a really gentle cleanser that's
effective at removing dirt oil makeup
and pollution
without disrupting the skin's barrier
very much and so that makes it really
good for sensitive skin
in clinical testing 97 of people with
fragile or sensitive skin
found they had a soothing effect from
this cleanser i've talked to so many
dermatologists and makeup
artists and people with sensitive skin
who also rave about this
now not all micellar waters are
formulated for sensitive skin but this
one has a number of features that makes
it really good
it has a skin friendly ph of 5.5 and
it's fragrance free and it contains
one single gentle surfactant now i know
we tend to think of surfactants as
harsh irritating ingredients but it's
actually a really broad category
unlike a lot of rinse-off cleanses and
other micellar waters on the market
this only has one super gentle non-ionic
surfactant ingredient
it's a skin softening amole moisturizer
that can actually counteract irritation
the water they use is also special it's
highly purified injection quality water
and in a lot of other cosmetic products
the water has endotoxins which
for most people is okay but if you have
very sensitive skin
it can be irritating i love this
cleanser you can use it as the first
step of a double cleansing routine
or i usually use it as a standalone
cleanser i use it with reusable cotton
pairs
mine are from bamboo face and i found
that these are really gentle
i used to use it with cheap cotton pads
and i found that my skin was getting a
bit sensitive and that was actually
because the cotton pad was rough
once i switched to a softer pad i found
that i didn't have issues so it was just
the physical exfoliation from the cotton
pad
so if i have makeup on i'll probably use
two cotton pads if i don't have makeup
i'll just use
one and then wipe it all over my face
then chuck this into the laundry
it also used to be my travel cleanser
back when we were actually traveling
i've also started using this in the
morning just as a morning cleanse
if you know my skincare routine i used
to just splash my face with water
and then pat it off because my skin's
really dehydration prone
but my skin's changed so much from
wearing masks after seeing a derma
clinician which is what we call
estheticians in australia she suggested
that maybe
i should cleanse my face in the morning
as well maybe that one cleanse in the
evening wasn't quite enough
so i've just started doing this i'll
keep you updated on how that goes
so apart from the micellar water which i
think is my one big
love from bioderma they have lots of
other great products i feel like
everyone in my family is now using at
least one bioderma product
another of my favorites is the sebum
foaming gel cleanser which is what i use
a lot of the time when i do a proper
cleanse
i've reviewed the sebum rage before it
contains a bunch of actives that
really help with pimples without drying
out your skin
so it helps with poor clogging and oil
and the whole range works really well
alongside traditional
acne treatments i also love the autoderm
range especially in winter it's great
for dry skin it's really good for
strengthening your barrier
and restoring lipids the next product
i'm talking about is kate somerville's
xfolicade
this is a rinse off exfoliating product
i guess you could call it a peel
or a mask you're meant to leave it on
for about two minutes
and this is my catcher product for when
i've forgotten to exfoliate
i use this a lot in the shower and
because it's rinse off it fits in really
easily with the rest of my routine
i don't have to worry about whether or
not it's going to interact with
something else or peel up
this is a chemical and physical and
enzyme exfoliant so it's got alpha
hydroxy acid it's got lactic acid
bha which is salicylic acid it has tiny
silica scrubbing granules so you
apply it by massaging it on for about 30
seconds
and then you'd leave it on after that
for you're meant to leave it on for a
total of two minutes i'm sure i've left
it on for longer without problems
there's also three types of enzymes in
this it's got papaya pumpkin and
pineapple enzymes
so it's basically ticked off every
exfoliation category i regularly use
apart from maybe
peeling gel and phase now this is a bit
expensive it's a bit more bougie than
i normally go for but it lasts for ages
so
i only use about a pencil a race's worth
every time and i think in total
i think i'm on my second tube they also
recently launched a 15 mil version which
is a bit more affordable so it's great
if you're not sure if you want to commit
to
a proper tube yet i've tried some other
peel products
but i always end up going back to this
because it works really well
it has all three types of exfoliants but
it also just has a really great texture
it's a thick green paste and it stays on
your skin really well
it doesn't drip down your face when
you're in the shower with all the steam
a lot of other peel products are very
liquid and very runny so
when i'm in the shower i can feel it
dripping down my face this one does not
so i am still paranoid enough to keep it
above my eyebrows but
yeah i haven't really felt this running
into my eyes yet and i still have my
eyes
next i have the paula's choice point
three percent rational and two percent
pecutial treatment
i really like this because it has this
combination bucutial is a plant extract
that helps with wrinkles and
hyperpigmentation
and it's been marketed as like an
alternative to retinol
it really isn't it's not a retinoid it
doesn't work the same way
even though it has a similar overall
effect but
so do a lot of other ingredients in skin
care but it is still a pretty promising
ingredient
now according to paula's choice the
pecutial can help the retinal work more
effectively
i don't know what evidence they have for
this i tried looking through their
references but they have a really awful
referencing system so i can't tell what
paper they're talking about
anyway this is a really nice light
lotion apart from the retinol ambicucial
there's also peptides and skin soothing
ingredients
and so that means we have a rational
product that isn't all that irritating
which means you don't have to be that
careful with the application
some nights i'm just too tired to
carefully measure out a tiny bit of
tretinoin i can't trust myself with that
responsibility
because it's got that combination of
ingredients i don't feel like i need to
use
extra products and because my skin is
more on the oily side this works as my
moisturizer as well
if your skin is a bit drier then maybe
that won't work you might need an extra
product
along the same lines this is kate ryan's
total nutrition night repair complex
i've raved about this product before
it's a very similar idea it's an
all-in-one product that just makes your
skin look really nice the next day
it has a bit of everything it's got
niacinamide retinol acetate
centella extract and antioxidants so
this is really great for when i want my
skin to look a bit
nicer but i also don't want to risk any
sort of irritation so
the night before filming a video now on
nights when i feel a bit more capable of
using trash i
really love the claire's midnight blue
calming cream
this is really good for mixing with
tretinoin and it calms the skin down a
bit so if i go a little bit
overboard on the trash then i'm a bit
safer
and it also helps the tretinoin spread
over skin much faster so i just mix it
on the palm of my hand with
about a half pea-sized amount of treason
on and then spread it all over
i've also been enjoying glow recipes lip
pop so there are skin care brand that
have
recently branched out and they've
launched lip products and body products
they have a lot of fruit branding so
this smells delicious it smells like
watermelon
it's a really rich soft moisturizing lip
balm and it also doubles up as a lip
scrub
it's got little sugar granules in it
that dissolve over time
and alpha hydroxy acids and so i use
this at night
it also has a little bit of a stain in
it i have the sort of coloring where i
look a little bit dead if i don't have
some sort of color on my face especially
on the lips
and so wearing this at night means that
when i wake up in the morning my lips
are already
sort of a little bit made up and so if i
just wake up
five minutes before a zoom call i don't
look too bad
i hope you like the video if you have
any other product suggestions for me to
incorporate into my
lazy skincare toolkit let me know you
can give it a thumbs up
and subscribe for more videos like this
you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog for more of the
science behind beauty products
see you next time to nerd out more